Mr fetterman turning to the next issue  Dennis Thank you Lisa let's turn to what  has become one of the key themes of this  race Fitness to serve no oh no  individual questions there will be no  rebuttals allowed Mr fetterman we begin  with you you suffered as you mentioned a  moment ago a stroke four days before the  May primary last week you released this  note from your doctor saying you can  work full Duty in public office but you  have not released your detailed medical  records the doctor is a donor to his  campaign by the way Mr fetterman will  you pledge tonight to release those  records in the interest of transparency  you had 60 seconds  to be for transparency is about showing  up I'm here today to have a debate I  have you know speeches in front of 3 000  people in Montgomery County you know all  across Pennsylvania big big crowds you  know I believe if my doctor believes  that I'm fit to serve and and that's  what I believe is appropriate